les mains dans la terre pour planter des
graines ou pour couper des vieux radis
afin de créer du compost les enfants de
l'école maternelle des bestiaires sont
motivés on peut pas la manger parce que
la glène qu'est ce qu'on va faire après
en fait
les grandes sections avaient rendez vous
au magasin débat était de maurepas pour
un atelier sur le compostage et le
jardinage moi je m'occupe plus de la
partie potager donc nous là on va
vraiment être sur la préparation du
terrain
quelques plantations va vraiment essayer
de leur expliquer un peu touché
uniquement qu'on fait à cause du roe
courant de la saison
préparez les bacs nourrir le sol tout ce
qui est autour un peu d'aidé de la
production de légumes moi de mon côté je
vais la représenter compostage de
surface est également leur montrer
comment on peut réduire ses déchets avec
le magasin grand marché vrac en
apportant des bocaux et en se servant
soi même l'objectif transmettent des
gestes éco-responsables aux enfants et
les sensibiliser à l'environnement l'un
d'eux des salades et
ils sont des vrais vecteurs
d'information auprès de leurs parents
donc comme le compostage ça va être
obligatoire fin 2023 on va être obligé
de trier ces biodéchets donc en passant
par eux les parents les écouter et ça
leur donne envie de tester le compostage
donc les enfants sont très investis et
mettre les mains dans la terre ça marche
toujours pour un enfant de 5 ans et si
en plus ça peut lui permettre de prendre
déjà des bonnes habitudes de citoyen
nous en tant qu'enseignants pour nous
c'est une très belle opportunité puis
c'est au tour de l'école de reproduire
les mêmes gestes dans la cour de récré
lundi 4 avril il utilisait pour la
première fois leur propre compost pour
planter des radis
toutes ces actions s'inscrivent dans la
volonté d'obtenir le label de 3 des
écoles en démarche de développement
durable en fait on doit rédiger un
document qui répertorie toutes les
actions passées en cours et futurs au
sein de l'école dans diverses domaine en
lien avec les os des délais dit cet
objectif de développement durable qui
sont des objectifs internationaux
décernés par l'éducation nationale le
label devrait être décerné d'ici la fin
de l'année scolaire il permet de
récompenser les établissements dans leur
engagement pour l'environnement en outre
le projet de composteurs et de jardins
potagers la maternelle a mis en place
des actions pour trier ses déchets ou
pour recycler ses fournitures scolaires